before we get started a big thanks to
our friends over at nordvpn for
sponsoring today's video if you're
unfamiliar vpn stands for virtual
private network a service that protects
your internet connection and privacy
online encrypting your data and
protecting you from others finding out
about all that weird stuff you might be
searching for on the internet
so whether you're in a foreign land and
you need access to your favorite content
or you're just sick of bandwidth
throttling or if you're like me
and you have a ton of devices that need
to be connected at all times because
you've got kids living in your house and
you know you should never oh never mind
head on over to nordvpn.com
starttalkvpn for 70 off the two-year
plan that's n-o-r-d-vpn.com
starttalkvpn for 70
off
that's right
seven zero
so what are you waiting for your
unsecured internet to do something for
you
step up your privacy game with nordvpn
[Music]
chuck time for another explainer all
right sounds are your game you're always
game that's good about you chuck yeah
well you know i i i wanna i wanna know
more too you wanna okay yeah okay yeah
it's like every time we're done with the
explainer i feel like a star with a
rainbow should go over my head the more
you know the more you know there it is
so so we recently did a an explainer you
could probably find it in our in our
pages on boiling water oh yeah that was
okay there was a lot going on there so i
thought
why not talk about freezing water okay
okay i mean why not
all right
you got you got a problem with that no i
don't okay yeah i mean freezing water
doesn't do much for me as much as
boiling water yeah boiling is it's
pretty useful yeah right uh and so but
so
here you go
okay if you put uh put a a container of
water in the freezer okay
hold the ice cubes aside because those
are harder to maneuver for this
experiment that i'm suggesting get like
a pitcher like a plastic pitcher uh fill
it you know halfway up with with water
all right right
now
measure its temperature
presumably came out of the cold water
faucet so cold it might be
45 degrees or something i don't know
whatever we're we're in america is
fahrenheit okay so it's 45 degrees and
so there it is
you write it down
put down what time you made that
measurement okay
come back
an hour later okay
measure the temperature
it might be 40 degrees
okay
uh write down the time and the
temperature all right and you come back
again it might be
35 degrees
come back and write it down
so what's happening is there is heat
inside the water
that the colder air
in the refrigerator is sucking out of it
okay
that sucking that's the wrong word there
it is extracting it so the water is
losing heat to the air
in the freezer
are we going to get sense makes sense
okay by the way if you don't have like a
big freezer and you have like a little
freezer just use a plastic cup it'll
work just the same except it'll freeze
faster because there's less water in a
plastic cup so maybe make your trips
every 30 minutes to do this all right
also if you have it in a pitcher and you
put it in the little freezer you'll
you'll just spill it all over the
freezer and you'll just you'll just end
up with a block of ice
right yeah okay so
let's keep doing this
so all this heat energy is going into
the air
and then you have compressors and things
that are taking the heat out of the
heated air that's in the freezer itself
and it goes onto the coils in the back
of the freezer right and that's why the
back of every freezer is warm yeah
that's the heat that used to be in the
food you put inside the freezer that's
why mice like to build their little nest
under there yes they do because they're
mammals and they like staying warm the
way we do right okay okay
so
let's go back what was what was the last
temperature we measured chuck uh 40 a 40
and then we do it again it's 35 then you
do it again like a half hour later it's
32 degrees okay
okay oh wait a minute and you see some
ice
starting to for form on the top surface
yes right okay all right well it's just
a film just break through it put the
thermometer in take another measurement
uh you know half hour later
it's still 32 degrees okay okay take the
thumb out leave it in another half hour
go back there's more frozen
but there's still some water down there
punch through take the temperature it's
still 32 degrees
it's still 32 degrees well this doesn't
sound like the water is really
cooperating
i'm just gonna say
everything was going perfectly the water
didn't get the memo okay and then the
water didn't get the memo that hey we're
supposed to be dropping the temperature
because we're freezing okay so here's at
this point more and more is getting cold
so why don't you leave the thermometer
in there if it's one of these meat
thermometers you can see what is this
that's a little metal
did vegetarians call them meat
thermometers you know i don't know
casserole thermometer so at the top you
can read it while it's in there so just
leave it in there
and then go back another half hour it's
still 32 degrees
so you had been dropping the temperature
over a couple of hours or a couple of
intervals of 30 minutes and then the
temperature stopped dropping
okay it stopped dropping
the freezer's still working yeah it's
still pulling heat out of the cup and
the thing is still freezing okay
and so eventually the entire thing
freezes right you go back look at the
thermometer it's still 32 degrees
okay then take another half hour break
go back
now it's 30 degrees
now it's 25 degrees
okay 20 degrees and then 15 degrees and
if you're a good red-blooded healthy
freezer it's 10 degrees 5 degrees and
most freezers will get you between 0 and
5 degrees whoa so
so why the plateau why the plateau
because
it takes energy
to completely stop the moving molecules
in liquid water
okay that takes energy
so while you are slowing down the moving
molecules right okay and the temperature
is dropping because the temperature is
the average speed with which the
molecules are vibrating the average
kinetic energy of the molecule so as
that happens
the molecules get to a point where they
can't
vibrate any slower
without becoming solid
so so they're just like i can't do no
more
i just
i just can't do no more
i'm so tired is that what they sound
like i'm so tired of vibrating
i can listen you can listen to them
[Laughter]
i'm just exhausted
just go on without me
oh [ __ ] i do declare
that is the phrase that would be spoken
in that moment at that time and so all
that extra energy getting
taken out of the water is serving to
create the ice
wow okay
then
when the ice is frozen we have solid
water
and those molecules have vibrations too
but now they're vibrating in a solid
lattice all right and you can slow down
those vibrations but you can only do it
while it's in the in the frozen state
while it's in its solid state so
so so now only when the whole thing
turns to ice
all right
will the temperature now drop for what's
in there
and so that's why you get the plateau
and so most people i've spoken to are
not thinking about the temperature of
ice
they think that all ice is just frozen
at 35 degrees no no you can have very
cold ice all right you have ice at zero
degrees so now you make ice cubes all
right pull out an ice cube at zero like
i said most good freezers take it down
to zero anywhere between zero and five
put that in your drink
so now the drink
will cannot melt the ice
until what happens
till the molecules start moving again
right so it has so the ice goes in at
zero degrees what happens to the
temperature of the ice
um well the temperature of the ice would
stay 98 no
not not no it is ice at zero degrees
okay you put it in your drink but now
wouldn't it wasn't a drink actually
start taking the
no wouldn't the ice start taking the
uh the heat from the drink it starts
pulling it in yes because it's okay okay
the same way your freezer does yes yes
chuck so the ice becomes your freezer
basically inside the glass inside the
glass it's in reverse freezer all right
right so the ice says give me some of
your heat
give me your your you know okay and so
what does that heat do it doesn't melt
the ice because the ice can't melt it
melt at zero degrees so what it does is
by extracting heat from the liquid the
liquid is now losing heat and it must
lower its temperature because
and the glass are not moving as quickly
because of the ice that's pulling out
the heat corrections and you know the
temperature of the ice is rising
in response to this okay then let me
tell you something wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait i'm not done here go ahead go ahead
go ahead the ice
keeps the temperature of the ice keeps
rising until it hits
32 degrees degrees
then it'll still take energy out of the
drink but now at the cost
of diluting the drink because now you're
picking because it's going back to water
back to water correct okay
there you have it if you don't like
science after this [ __ ]
something wrong with you
so what you could do is take really cold
ice put it in your drink
and
um and if you don't want to dilute your
drink you leave it in for like you know
30 seconds because this will happen fast
and then take it out and put in another
ice cube then you won't dilute your
drink you'll drop the temperature of
your drink and by the way if you take a
really cold ice cube dip it in the drink
and pull it out again real fast you'll
see the drink frozen on the surface of
the ice and the ice cube is intact try
that experiment look at that like do use
tongs to do that really cool
okay
chuck that's that's uh ice that's bar
drinks 101.
there you go now now you know how to
make cold drinks with somebody or
several people
you can make cold drinks for several
people with just a few ice cubes it's
just a few ice cubes just share that out
all right we got to call it quits there
that's been an ice cube explainer on
star talk thanks for being there chuck
as always keep looking up
[Music]